new homes are being built by the
thousands Valley Wide some Realtors say
the rising interest rates are making it
harder to sell older homes so they point
to all the incentives that Builders are
providing eight news now reporter Ryan
Matthews shows us The Dilemma for buyers
the owner works from home so great great
work space two bedrooms a new backyard
and over 1700 square feet Trish Nash has
been trying to sell this in Lake Las
Vegas built in 2020 for four months
ready to move in and yet we have the
Builder who is offering deep deep
incentives and despite a hundred and
sixty thousand dollars in upgrades this
house just can't seem to sell homes like
this facing competition from homes
currently being built at the end of the
day people want to get what they want
Andrew Levitt with Pinnacle Lending
Group says in a way Builders are paying
for buyers to move in they prepay the
interest they get it down into 4.99 and
when rates are at six and seven percent
right now getting anything in the fours
is a huge savings he calls it a 3-2-1
buy down starting low the buyer pays an
interest rate that goes up gradually
over three years the Builder pays the
difference in the meantime which Levitt
says can be thousands of dollars so
you've got this beautiful backyard but
the taxes eventually catch up older
homes he says have tax rates capped on
the date of construction meaning less of
a monthly payment you know a couple
hundred bucks each month and that's
where the payment is going to be lower
and make more sense and more
affordability this will actually be my
first time buying a home it leaves
buyers like Jason McDonald with
questions buy new choose what you want
in the house and pay higher prices later
or buy old risk having to upgrade or
replace certain aspects later but with
the monthly costs up front I do want to
make sure that I get
my money's worth